to Stipe John with the marketing of the
UFC do more pay-per-views than Francis
Fury this is the first time you have
like a guy who's on this side greatest
knockout artist in the UFC who was
championed left fighting the pound for
pound undefeated best boxing world
they're both heavyweights yeah you don't
think two million I think he does two
mil I think two yeah now we're looking
at the numbers anything about Floyd and
Connor did even though you had the UFC
machine behind that that shot lands on
anybody I don't care who you are that's
why this fight is more intriguing than
Connor versus Floyd
way more intriguing because Connor he's
still a small dude man he doesn't have
that one shot knockout power the best
defensive box of all time even he landed
uppercut Francis lands out uppercut this
thing's over that's why it does two
million miles yeah